good afternoon everyone
and
i want to start with thanking
dr
freeman and dr allison for
generous invitation to give this
colloquium and for your
kind introduction
so
i'm going to today talk about a couple
of things
actually
you know four different uh four
different topics so four mini talks
so i'm going to start with the
motivation behind uh the work that i did
with a large group of people most
importantly jorge rivers and eugenia
calne that i have named as co-authors on
this talk
so i'm going to start with
basically the basis of coupling human
and earth system models
what is the philosophy what's the
foundation and why do we do this work
then i'm going to go right into
the handy model
whose paper was published on april the
2nd
and created a lot of buzz
all around the world i went over the
media
and i think that's why i'm here
then
there is coupled human climate water
model koa
which is the real system that we are
we have modeled and i will show like
different examples different regions
that we apply policies and we look at
the future of water sources i'm going to
end with
just one slide for the final thoughts
okay so
looking at the
growth of human population and
consumption
so this graph shows what has happened to
the human population here as solid red
line
and what has happened to human
consumption if you
agree that gdp per capita
average gdp per capita can be a good
proxy
for
consumption so starting from year 0
and going to year 2000
we can see that what has happened you
know for a long time for actually a long
time before that year zero
uh going back to the beginning of
agriculture
human population has been pretty much
constant maybe growing
very slowly linearly
but then we get here to
around 1700 1750s
and the beginning of industrial
revolution and starting using
non-renewables and fossil fuels
and then we can see that there has been
an explosion of not just population
the red line
but also
an explosion in consumption
so
our impact on our planet
is the product of these two factors
population and consumption per capita
so when you think of the impact you can
see that it must be it must be growing
at an super exponential rate
because of this
so
we can think of
the human system has embedded into the
earth system because earth system
provided provides us with the sources
for our economic growth for inputs
to our economy all the materials energy
and also absorbs
all the results of this production all
the emissions all the pollution
so
this whole human economy is part of the
earth system it's
it's integrated and it should be
integrated with this whole system
most importantly because
if you look at this
so before
in the beginnings of times until you
know three hundred years ago
or even like 100 years ago some people
can argue until 1960s where they had the
super exponential growth
this was the situation we had
small like human system
and the earth system was huge so we
could basically
say that approximate the earth system as
infinite
so we could think of we are living in an
infinite world with infinite resources
infinite capacity to absorb
all the emissions
and
what has happened now is that this
little part immune system has grown to
dominate
the earth system
so that's why we need to
couple if you want to understand what's
happening with the evolution with the
dynamics of the human system or the
earth system we need to look at these
two
coupled together with bi-directional
feedbacks
so
as a history of earth system models
what we've had
as you know starting back in 1960s you
know first models of the atmosphere
were developed by atmospheric scientists
and physicists
then
newer parts were added in the following
decades we had land we had ocean we had
sea ice
multiple parts that were added
but for example until 1980s 1986 67 mid
80s
we had complex
we had complex atmospheric models and
ocean models
and they had interactions
through
one-way
feedbacks
so atmospheric temperatures could change
the sea surface temperature but not
other way around
and sea surface or the oceans could
change the humidity
but
nothing like back to the sea surface so
with those models
not being fully coupled we couldn't
predict el nino or
enzo
el nino la nina we couldn't predict it
so mark kane in 80s he developed a
simple model
that had both atmosphere and ocean and
they were coupled
with bi-directional feedbacks
so when he did that
he could predict el nino a year in
advance
successfully
and
that was one of the biggest um
discoveries back then
biggest you know and biggest uh
achievements for for modeling
so in a similar fashion in a similar
fashion what we propose is to couple
population and the human system through
bi-directional feedbacks to the human
system
and build
a fully coupled human earth system model
which i will show here
so this is a prototype schematic of that
model
which has
um
basically the earth system itself
atmosphere land ocean
there will be a water system in that
whole
five sector model
in agriculture and food
energy and resources
and population population and the huma
as part as the most important part of
the human system
and all of these sectors
they're coupled to each other through
bi-directional feedbacks
so basically for example population is
connected
to the water system
through feedbacks that goes in both
directions not just one direction
and one of the most important
uh
parts of this figure is that top box
policies
so that's the major difference of a
human system
and
of a coupled human earth system
and the fully physical system or fully
natural system
because a physical system
it's evolution is fully governed by the
physical laws
so you can't change anything
but when you have a human system
and when you couple it
to the earth's up to the earth system to
a physical system
lots of interactions they depend on our
decisions
so that's why policies act as drivers
for
this whole coupled system coupled model
and what we do we
look at
different policies different choices we
have for our decisions and we try to
look at possible future scenarios
so
policies are what we need
so we make policies based on
based on different you know different
uh
things that we see from the system so we
can actually make inputs to the policies
as you say
and we do we do make inputs so those
policies are based on
are based on the evolution of each of
these sectors so those policies for
example look at a certain variable
in the system let's say population
growth
and then determine
where how should we
change that rate so that would be a
policy
that
um that is affected by
the change of variables in the system so
yes
question
bi-directional basically
physics certainly isn't
everything else is strictly speaking
bi-directional well i suppose some
people would argue that there's an error
from waste into policies yeah
yeah so with this bi-direction
because
i think we have have some bi-directional
arrows and uni-directional imperials so
you see me you're making a
subtle distinction somehow right
there are arrows that are only going one
way in that chart correct yeah but then
we have this like so they're like the
bi-directional is not everything so not
everything can be coupled in a
bi-directional way but the whole point
is that the full system
will be bi-directional through indirect
indirect feedbacks so it's like impact
of an impact that makes it fully coupled
okay
so
with this
i would like to go into a description of
the handy the handy model so handy was
our first attempt
at understanding this fully coupled
systems
so we sat down and we said what's the
easiest way what's the easiest way to
understand the interaction of
human population and resource use
on this planet
and we started with the predator prey
model
looking at population as a predator and
resources as prey
and then we built
this model handy
there are a couple of differences so we
did why did we thought that
you know the whole population doesn't
interact with resources in the same way
so we divided the population stock into
elites and commoners so population was
divided into two stocks
and then we introduced an accumulation
of wealth so a new stock
that
takes the result of physical depletion
and physical production and saves it
and then for
one of the key results of handy
was this notion of carrying capacity
that we introduce in there i mean it has
existed but we introduced it
specifically for handy for this model
and as we'll see later
it proves to be
a critical
measure and notion for understanding
and realizing sustainability
okay
so
what's happening with these collapses
has there been collapses
many many times in the history
you know lots of them they have been
unnoticed because essentially those
civilizations didn't exist afterwards so
they went away
but there are still like hundreds of
collapses that have been documented and
archaeologists have found that most
recent result is from a
work that was done in europe a
multi-million euro project
directed by shannon also
downey
was one of the professors at umd
he was also involved in this project and
they look at a huge
body of data a huge collection of data
archaeological evidence at certain sites
over the europe
and they find that there have been 23
societal collapses
over past 8 000 years
and this is over
those specific places specific sites
that they have looked into
and out of these 23 collapses
they figure out that external forcing
wasn't the cause of such collapses
but it they these collapses happened
because of an internal endogenous
uh issue and that that was overrun and
carrying capacity of the system
so
another interesting result from wavelet
analysis of their data
is that
is that the
time scale
for
prosperity and collapse these cycles of
the societies were about three to five
hundred years which happens to be
matching the results we get from handy
and then
um
so with this i'm just gonna go
right into a typical
collab scenario from handy
as you can see so these are the four
variables we
model in the system this is like natural
resources this is population of
commoners
this is population of elites or the
equivalent
population which is multiplied by this
number kappa
which is the inequality factor
and this is accumulated wealth the gray
line accumulated wealth
and the the orange
curve here the orange line is our
carrying capacity
so
when population crosses carrying
capacity
we find that in all these experiments
that's the time that corresponds to the
time when wealth
has started to decline
and this result gives us a practical way
to understand and measure carrying
capacity and estimate carrying capacity
in a real system because in a real
system
we don't know like all these parameters
in this model and it's much more
complicated but we can still understand
it based on the time that the
accumulated wealth starts declining
so going into the model
itself as i said it's a minimal model
with only four
uh dynamical equations for differential
equations
this is xc is the commoner population x
e is the elite population y is nature
and w is wealth
so
these are birth rates death rates for
elites and commoners which are different
we'll see shortly depends on consumption
levels and because consumption levels
are different those death rates are
different
nature we assume that it regrows
uh with this logistic function here
and then there is
depletion of nature which goes directly
into production
physical production and then there's
consumption for commoners and
consumption for elites
those two equations you can write beta c
minus alpha c all of that times xc would
that be correct that's correct actually
the
real effect is the difference of those
two
but for simplicity for being you know um
for vis for better visibility in this
case we just kept them separate and
because you know people think of birth
rates and death rates separately and how
they change so we look at the birth
rates and we look at the death rates and
we show that death rates are we
basically assume that the death rates
change
yeah
so there are people who don't who do
live forever
these are the rates
okay so
so here are the consumption rates you
know as i said we assume that there's a
different level kappa inequality level
factor between elites and commoners
so
that describes the
um that describes the difference
and
consumption decreases as soon as wealth
hits a lower threshold
so
when there's no wealth you know people
have to reduce their consumption
but because
elites consume at a much higher level
their consumption
goes below the critical level much later
than commoners
because of that
you know we assume that the death rates
are proportional to this consumption
levels
and because of that as you can see the
death rates
for elites goes into the famine
uh regime
later than
much later than the commoners
so this gives that delay
and
carrying capacity that important notion
which
uh which is guiding
guiding us for the rest of our models in
the water model in the energy model
in the land and agriculture model
so carrying capacity
for handy specifically within this
mathematical structure
we define it as the level of equilibrium
population
and
it's given by is proportional as you can
see to the regeneration gamma of nature
the depletion factor delta
maximum capacity of nature
lambda
consumption per capita s
and eta which is a factor depends which
depends on the death rate and birth rate
so
we show that this carrying capacity can
be maximized
at
this level
by choosing
uh by choosing the the depletion
factor
at uh
at an optimal level
really technology affects
carrying capacity right
denser agricultural practices increased
carrying capacity and i'm not sure i see
how that's reflected that's true yes we
don't uh we explain in our paper
uh why we don't include technology in
this model you know first of all we
don't want to we didn't want to
complicate the model too far
secondly technology can have both
positive and negative impacts
and then technology has multiple things
there is technology for
consumption which can improve which can
improve our level i will show it in
in the next person in the next part of
the presentation for the water model how
technology can improve water carrying
capacity in the region
but there's also technology for
extraction
you know when you improve extraction
technology that actually results in
faster depletion
and then there is this rebound effect
you know javon's paradox rebound effect
which causes
which is like a social effect you know
so
it's an indirect effect which results in
increased
levels of consumption
when
uh technologies become more efficient
so for
those number of reasons then for keeping
it simple we just didn't model
technology explicitly in this
in this uh
work in this in handy and that's why
that's why basically carrying capacity
stays at the constant level for each
scenario
all right
so
i'm going to go right into
um
these scenarios we which we have
so we looked at three different types of
societies
well the first the first type is the
egalitarian society where we just assume
we have no elites so basically
all the population works
so it's commoners everybody works and
everybody consumes at the same level
egalitarian society
and then we look at multiple uh
different possible cases within the
society so
um
first of all we show we can come to this
optimal equilibrium level
so that's a possibility for sure and
population lands to the maximum level of
carrying capacity that's why so pm is
the carrying capacity
and
population lands to that level so this
is all perfect everything looks good
then
we increase the
depletion factor the production we
increase that
and then we see that okay we can
cross over the carrying capacity so
carrying capacity comes lower than the
maximum because delta is not at its
optimal level
so
population crosses carrying capacity but
the overshoot is not too large
so
it's still like a reasonable overshoot
it just oscillates comes back down and
eventually
um
eventually converges to the level of
carrying capacity
so everything goes into equilibrium even
though it's not the optimal equilibrium
then if we increase delta beyond that
even further what happens is that the
system goes into these cycles
of prosperity and collapse
so we'll see these cycles
that you know take about this
500 years
and
then there is like another cycle
starting and it can push the system into
those cycles have fun
so here it is
so the push if you push the system to
push the production level and depletion
beyond a certain level
then we can push the system into a full
collapse or type n as we call a type and
collapse which in this case
happens just because of over depletion
so it's just over depletion
that is at play and this is something
that other models before
handy
similar models in the same class models
that were published in ecological
economics and
started with the works with the paper of
brander and taylor
so
those models they all look at over
depletion and they can show this
however you know not those models
couldn't do full collapses
and that was one of the things that he
realized uh
you know after our reviewers told us
about it we figured out that
so handy is special because it can it
can
reproduce these full collapses which
those other models couldn't
and that's because of accumulated wealth
so
those predator prey models they go into
cycles because you directly prey on your
resources and resources go down
population goes down and then it keeps
oscillating so it goes into a cycle
when you add this accumulated wealth
what you can do you can start
using because you what you consume is
the wealth
so when
even though when nature's
pretty much out
you keep growing because you still have
the savings and you rely on those
and
with that you can
push the system into a full collapse
so
so these are
that's actually a comment we received
from a
uh
lobby anti-nasa lobby in dc
that told us why don't you go to extra
terrestrial resources and bring them
down here to use them for
yeah accumulated wealth canned food
doesn't last long
so
so you have to take you know take the
numbers here with a
uh with a grain of salt you know the the
fact is
you know these numbers in reality you
know in a specific in a specific system
depending on what type of resources they
can be back and forth but the mechanisms
the under the underlying mechanism which
causes this delay would be pretty much
the
same resources or could it be other
phenomena like
let me show you that so
there could be like another factor which
is inequality which i will show in the
in the following
results
okay
so let's next go to
um the second type of societies
so this is for equitable society
so equitable society is basically where
we have
both elites and commoners
the inequality factor kappa
equals one
so which means they use they consume at
the same level so basically we have
workers and non-workers
and we show you know we show like
again the same set of results so results
we got are robust they
they we can reproduce them in this case
with differences but still we can have
optimal equilibrium where total
population goes to your
carrying capacity
then
we can have as long as we don't cross
this carrying capacity by too far
we can still you know converge to that
level to the level of carrying capacity
and observed that as i said before in
all these experiments you know the time
that population crosses this level of
carrying capacity is the time when
wealth starts declining so that gives us
a good proxy for estimating what's the
real carrying capacity of the system
then we go into
those cycles of prosperity and collapse
and eventually
the full collapse of the system
in an equitable society
happens as before
so this type of this equitable society
we we did an experiment so we figure is
that we said you know what's happening
if
we want to make this
um make this system this very same
system
sustainable can we make it sustainable
by doing anything
say
changing the ratio of
workers and non-workers basically by
increasing in
unemployment
so one way
one way in this system to reach
sustainability
is to
reduce you know total depletion which
can be done
by
uh reducing you know work hours per week
or you know average could average
depletion per capita
and the second way we figured out
is to increase
unemployment rate
and this
result resembles so basically in this
case these are the same things
everything it's just higher on
unemployment
and it goes into sustainability so this
sort of resembles results of
paper by uh
knight rosa and julius shore
which was published last year and they
looked at data from oecd from 1960s 70s
up until now
and they look at the impact of work
hours on sustainability of societies
so
it basically shows that sustainability
is a result of
uh
can is
changing or the employ unemployment rate
can be related to
uh keeping sustainability in a system as
you can think of it you can in our paper
we give the example of germany versus
u.s you know where germany keeps its
sustain its unemployment below five
percent by reducing work hours per week
to 30 hours
and u.s
we have you know much higher
unemployment and the work hours are much
higher so
this scenario here for the equitable
society
can uh show this fact through the simple
experiment
all right
so done with these examples
i'm gonna go into
the
um
go back to the very first experiment
that i showed you know egalitarian
society
optimal equilibrium everything
sustainable
now
i add a small initial seed of elites
to this
example and
the question is what will happen
if we add this small initial seed of
elites here
you know up to 500 years which is the
timeline here you know we have the 500
years
up to 500 years everything looks perfect
we seem to be on our path to equilibrium
even though we have that small seed of
elites
but what will happen any guesses
yeah that's true
so
this is what will happen
yeah so
so what happens this is actually one of
the
one of the other like uh unique
results that came from handy
so this case is basically the previous
case which was fully sustainable very
completely equilibrium but because of
these elites
they grow
to larger numbers they start depleting
wealth because they have a larger access
that drives down the
population of commoners here
and by driving that down
even though nature even though natural
resources regrow to the full capacity up
here
the system the system goes into a
collapse
because
uh labor is gone
and we think of this basically like the
maya collapse where they had this large
inequality
and even though after the collapse you
know their
forests and croplands they all grew to
be very lush and
um
so this is basically this what happens
to the nature so nature grew but still
the civilization the society collapsed
because of that large level of
inequality that they had
so
this result was
you know this factor of inequality was a
result was a factor that was not
considerate in the models prior to handy
and those models that
go after brander and taylor modeling
ecological economics
so this is type l
because it's labor basically because
labor collapses then the system
collapses type l collapse
and
then this is the
um
typical you know scenario which i showed
in the very beginning
type n irreversible full collapse of the
system where we have unequal society
so this is a situation where system
collapses
both because of over depletion so we
have high you know very high depletion
of resources and we have high
inequalities we are doing both of this
so even though we showed that either one
of them can independently push the
system into a collapse this one
um which is the typical case for
collapses like eastern islanders or
anasazi or
uh
many many other collapses in the gupta
marine chinese dynasties roman empire if
you look at most of them this is what
happens both high inequality
and
high
uh
high in depletion per capita
metrics
your use of chi and gamma
and i can understand i think
anthropomorphizing those curves
with wealth i should take commoners
elites and carrying capacity now i'm a
little fuzzy about what it means
for nature or wealth i'm presenting is
what dollars
so what do we measure nature and wealth
here we
actually use it use the same
uh we use the same units we call them
echo dollars we invented this units echo
dollars
because wealthier represents physical
wealth
so it's the direct result of
depletion which becomes production
so we call it echo dollars and does that
also go though for the actually biased
curves of commoners and elites too
oh
yeah
it should how do those relate to the
kind gamma
too
yeah
i use the original green so
so
carrying capacity v
as i showed before it really
it it's a function of
gamma which is the regeneration rate of
nature lambda nature carrying capacity
delta
which is the depletion rate and s which
is consumption per capita
not just this particular but like all of
them yeah so yeah so in the paper if you
look at them if you want to if you're
interested in all the details you should
look at the
paper and then we can available
yes
if the source code is available and the
paper is available everything is online
it's inventing
it's investing but it's also available
in python it's also available
in
um
in math lab in multiple languages so
yeah but
we wrote it originally with medicine
great question yes
i think
whatever it sounded like and since you
have a predator prey model sounds like
the elites are your predators
aha somebody actually
so somebody said jumping ahead
so actually somebody said that you know
we had a
that's an interesting thing so somebody
actually somebody said that so elites
are because it sounds like that or even
some of these articles which were on the
news you know
they had this under misunderstanding
that elites are the predators you know
no they're the same no the predator is
the whole population basically it's the
human population not the elites
and
population coming in
and one goes away if the other one shows
up
um
yeah
this predation from the elites and the
race
because they're dying last so predators
are the whole population so basically
and prey is the nature resources so
that's what goes in between you know the
predation the predations between
population and nature it's not it's not
between
the predators and nature and commoners
in wealth whatever
this basically becomes prey
if you're interested it's not so
somebody actually we have one of our
reviewers who said that
and we had to explain and he actually
suggested that to call elites
uh lions and predators and commoners
zebras
and in our model elites don't eat
commoners you know there's no like
lions eating zebras
but but i can discuss that
after the talk yeah
yeah yeah
we'll pray that you're praying
okay
so
back to this collapses is there any
um
any hope
in an unequal society because we know
that inequality
is essentially a nature of the social
system
so
can we reach sustainability in an
unequal society
any thoughts
so we actually show that yes we can
uh we can't reach sustainability as
herman daley who's one of the fathers of
ecological economics
said in his ten commandments for
sustainability a couple of years ago
he said you know we have to reduce
inequality to a level of 10. so we did
that experiment we reduced inequality to
that level 10
but we also had to reduce consumption
and we had to reduce uh
the population growth rates you know
reducing
modifying birth rates
basically
lots of other places you know or any
place that you want to be sustainable
you have to look at these three factors
particularly in handy so we had to
adjust inequality consumption rates and
population growth and then we could
bring an unequal society
into
an equilibrium which is optimal given
its um
given its situation at stake
and what happens if the overshoot
well as before
if we overshoot and
but don't overshoot by too much
then we can still manage to
converge to this equilibrium solution
so like some people say we are already
over our carrying capacity of the earth
well is there a hope we think there is
but
as long as we don't
start acting too late all right
so
with this
i
so with this i think
i would just go to conclusions from
handy juan
so we use this minimal model basically
to understand mechanisms behind
different
social dynamics particularly
sustainability and collapses of
societies
we we have this four variable model and
we did these thought experiments
so and that's what we use handy for just
you know for thought experiments that
help us understand
these interactions
and long-term evolution
so carrying capacity
was the single most important
measure
that
through experiments with handy
shows us
where we are in terms of our path and
our evolution towards sustainability
and
one interesting example was the
experiment we did in the
equitable
societies and we showed that
unemployment
and high unemployment and work hours are
directly related to
societal sustainability the example of
germany versus us
and
each of the two factors so this is what
handicap each of the two factors of
ecological strain
does depletion
of natural resources
and economic certification
which is level of inequality kappa each
of them can
separately
send the system into a collapse
and sometimes we do both of them then
it's going to be even worse
however
we showed that you know at the end and
other cases we show that sustainability
is definitely possible but we need to
have right policies and right decisions
so
so what's next after hadn't won we
actually
already have our
uh
because
in the
2007-2006 era by one definition of
employment the united states
unemployment rate was lower than
germany's they also had low reduced work
hours but they had higher unemployment
but
there's also definitions of employment
for which
things change a whole bunch what if
everybody works
45 hours a week
but
eighty percent of the people writing
poetry is their work
um and
so we have a high poetry consumption
which doesn't really have an ecological
effect right if i've chosen poetry
correctly
well but
so so what definition of employment and
what definition of consumption are you
getting
so consumption doesn't necessarily
fall in this way excellent question so
look at this experiments we did here you
know in the paper of night shore and
night rosa and shore
they
um
they explicitly show you know what what
are these like unemployment data that
they use from oecd data
so that's like a vertically shown in
this model the experiment that i showed
here
was basically unemployment meaning that
if you're into the elites so elites
don't do the physical production so as
you said you know those poets in this
case would be unemployed because they
don't do the physical production
and um that that one was the definition
we use
in in our experiments here
yeah exactly and in our experiment
unemployed the non-workers in equitable
society they don't consume more so we
assume they consume at the same level
but it's just they're not participating
in the physical labor physical
production and extraction from natural
resources so
we pass through our programs and call it
gdp
right yeah so that
that's true so they use wealth so that
goes into that goes into the consumption
they're producing and consuming products
so
well that's good for
that's where we're at water
making poems and you know we need we
need we just we just don't need the
physical resources you know we need like
spiritual resources so that goes into
the spiritual resources i guess in this
case
okay
so
um
what's happening with the
next generation next level of handy uh
we already
we already like looked into
a second generation of handy we've
already developed the second generation
paper is under
uh writing
so what happens with the second
generation is that we have you know in
handy one which i showed
we just have regenerating nature so
there's a regenerating nature that keeps
regenerating like forest crops
um
fisheries game animals those sort of
things so what happens if we add
non-renewables
fossil fuels
and renewable flows
which is like solar wind
things like that
and
so we also added the mechanism for
investment in accessibility capital
so we invest in a certain um
in certain sector of production
then we can improve that we can have
faster production so
we have that accessibility capital added
and then we have labor going into
different sectors of production sector
non-renewable renewable and regenerating
and renewable
and then we added the mechanism for
social mobility so what happens if we
add
um
social mobility so elites and commoners
can change
in between them
so
i'm just going to show like
only a couple of only a couple of
examples only a couple of examples and
results from handy too
so this is our classic full collapse
which we had again typical collapse
scenario
so just look at the timeline we have
about 500 years the cycle the population
here maximum is like 80 000 people in
this
on the units
so
and this is the situation
now the question is
what happens if we add
non-renewables to the system
if he had a stock a larger stock of
non-renewables
is that going to prevent collapse
exactly wow
you got the answer
it's actually just the lasik it has
another important
um
impact so here's the result
we had this non-renewable resources
so we go from 500 years for the timeline
we go to 700 years
so
it gives us a delay of about
about 200 years right so we get about
200 years extra but another important
thing that happens here
is if you look at this maximum rate you
know you remember it was 80 000 i was 4
million
so we can see that the peak population
increases by a factor of 20 20 30.
and if you think about it you know what
happened if you go back to the very
first
very first graph that i showed here
in my talk
about explosion of population and
consumption
in the past over the past decade over
the past century especially like past 50
years since 1960s
you can think about it you know somehow
how can it relate to this model you know
this thought experiment model and two
and
how come like it can capture that effect
that effective
maximum you know the peak population
being uh
raised by about 30 times and this delay
this delay that we get with collapses so
and
finally
you know we show that what happens with
an unequal society if we add renewables
you know if you switch to renewable
sources
again we'll see that
we get another 200 years
so we get another
like
a
couple centuries extra
but within the system if you look at it
it doesn't completely prevent the
collapse
as long as because you know because we
still have that high level of inequality
and no mobility
we show later that if we add mobility we
can bring this into
a sustainable state
but
so again it's important that we use
renewable sources
it's important that we
extract extracted resources sustainably
and it's important that
we have lower inequality
and mobility
in the society
okay
so
quick results from handy2
which we have you know these three types
of nature
mechanism for investment
in accessibility
adding non-renewables delayed for 200
and
increase the peak by 20 30 times
and adding renewables it delayed for
another 200 years
but since we had this inequality to
still push the system into a collapse
okay
so with this i want to go
um
into my
um basically
third part
of the talk
so
which is on
the real system this coupled
uh-huh
you can eat stored food so when you have
a gap between accumulated wealth between
nature goes to zero at that point you're
on stored food not accumulated wealth
because you can't eat accumulated well
well you've got stored food
so in this model
the
wealth is the physical wealth so
accumulated wealth is a stored food
essentially
correct
so what we can and
what to have we can keep it for a couple
decades you know it can't be stored for
a couple decades like grains you know if
you think about the historical case at
the time of joseph you know for example
they stored grains for seven years and
they could go through a drought for the
next seven years so it has happened but
you know as i said you have to take the
numbers with a grain of salt here
um
but accumulated wealth is
the physical
is the physical um
accumulation so you should plant trees
nature then nature didn't collapse
and and and well there might be biblical
stories of people storing food for seven
years
i'd like to see some actual examples
some documentary that
those are documented well okay
those are five to ten years i can buy
but 50 years i can't
which is all your numbers i have 50-year
gaps right in those cases yeah that's
population pretty quickly
again you know as i said you have to
take these numbers here with a grain of
salt you know again the system you know
the the mechanisms happening are the
same
and then you have also this issue of
converting you know accumulated wealth
you know somehow back to food
so now for example with refrigeration
with new techniques you can store it for
much longer
right you can store your food for
50 years
or 100 years
yeah because we have it
which drives your consumption way up
right so that's kind of awkward too
sorry
get there
things change as soon as the food
production goes to zero
because nope because
one of two things is true either you
notice that what's happening and start
producing food like crazy it starts
storing food like crazy which drives you
your nature to zero faster yeah
or your population collapses
it's no 50-year
thing here
so it does you know if you
you know you're uh as i said again you
know i just repeat you know i'm just
repeating myself you know this this
number
you know whether it's 50 years or like
10 years or 20 years or something
that's
um
that can be adjusted within the
parameters of the model so but the
mechanisms behind it you know the
mechanism behind it is still a similar
mechanism which you can you know we can
store the food for a number of years
or you know that they generally and you
can store the resources for a number of
decades and then
and then that can delay that can cause
this delay and
in collapses after after you have
depleted your
major resources natural resources but as
you say you know could be it could
happen much faster in reality and it
would
like the delay that delay is shorter
but
the delay could be shorter but it's
still there
historically so yeah
yeah great so
i'll be happy to discuss this you know
further
after the talk
so
going into
um
so i have to actually rush through this
one so this is the this is the coupled
uh so what time did should i end
5 30.
okay i think i should i will finish by
five there yeah
okay so
you know the model i showed in the very
beginning um
the coupled
the coupled system you know human earth
system model which i said we are doing
five five subsystems you know we're
doing the
the earth system water
energy
agriculture and population
so
out of this five so far we've done the
earth system you know climate model
water
and population and we have coupled them
together so we have this coupled human
climate water model
that we use to
um which is called you know this is
co-wall we call it koa couple water
model
and we use it to do experiments
and we apply it to the specific region
of phoenix ama watersheds or like with
these real numbers and data that we get
from the region
and
we do you know like a base run and then
we look at different policies different
water management options so we run the
model from 1900 to 2100 and we look at
the impacts of different uh management
physicians
so
again we use a minimal system minimal
model to focus on simplicity
to guide us
uh to guide us for understanding all the
interactions so that we are able to
understand all those interactions in the
system
we have population
those like state variables population
surface water ground water and fresh
water supply which is reservoir
reservoir
and we couple to the earth system
through
precipitation evaporation we couple it
to a river routing module rn
through river flow into the area and out
of the area and population is coupled
through demand and change in
population grade growth rates and
migration rates
so again this is the
these are like this is a graphical
representation
of
different state variables as i said
these are the couplings to the
precipitation evaporation compilation to
the
earth system model the climate model
river inflow outflow rates coupling to
the river routing there is recharge of
groundwater going here
withdrawal from surface and groundwater
recycling
the feedbacks here shown with red
between the fresh between available
water
which is you know population growth rate
including migration rates from a region
and
consumption and demand which is
determined by population
so
this is sort of like a schematic of this
co-wall and again shows you know all
those like variables all the connection
and the flow
in the system
on this side you see that uh the earth
system you want the icdb air
earth system
the
land
and river routing model
and over here we have the population
with all these connections
so
this is how we assume again that the
population growth rates change
we have this alpha similar to what you
saw in handy we also assume that as long
as we are above a certain consumption
rates
we are at the healthy death rates and as
soon as we drop below that the death
rates increase and the migration rates
have the same story as long as we beyond
we are beyond a certain rate
we have
um
we have a
population coming into the area
immigrating to the area
and when consumption decreases
population starts migrate out
so
this is one of the key factors here in
kowa
uh where we show what's the impact of
long-term policies of why they are
needed
we actually show this i will show in
these experiments that how important of
this long-term planning or long-term
policies we have so this is withdrawal
from withdrawal of water from surfaces
from surface water or groundwater and
this shows this factor n as that policy
knob
that we can you can change and see
what happens
if we have enough water in our sources
for this number of years or this number
of months down the road
then we can withdraw as much as we want
if we have less
then
we have to reduce it and then we can
change this limit we can change the
threshold by choosing this policy knob
and adjusting it okay
so
going right to the experiments
we did this
we did this you know
base base run
from 1900 as i said to 2100
we look at these variables most
importantly you know in these
experiments we're going to look at
population and groundwater because those
are the variables that
change
most
significantly in between different uh
scenarios that we show here
as
as you can see you know
groundwater
ends up at the level of about 300 ckms
here in this experiment and population
enzo has about uh
13 million people
so we'll go through
different experiments and we show we
compare what happens
okay first experiment
adding recycling
recycling is the from all of these
experiments recycling is the most
effective is the most effective
management option factory that we can
add to the system as you can see you
know we can increase the population from
you know 13 40 million here to about 23
million so it increases water carrying
capacity of the system that's for one
thing
and the second thing is that you can
look at the final level of groundwater
instead of ending up at 300 ckm cubic
kilometers we end up at about 550 which
is significantly better
so recycling
number one factor biggest factor
then we look at technology you know
going back to your question
about um
technology and this is technology and
dispensing so essentially for example
going from
flood irrigation
to drip irrigation so less consumption
of water or going from you know regular
shower heads to
conserving shower heads
so with technology
improving you know technology factor
we can look at
this differences so groundwater goes
from
300 to 490 which is still much higher
but not as high as
it was with the case of recycling
and population goes to about the same
level of about 24
million so technology definitely can
increase the carrying capacity if it's
not over compensated by increased
consumption
okay
what happens with the
transfer of transfer infrastructure you
know aging pipelines so
we look at the aging pipelines we if we
improve it you know we can improve the
carrying capacity a little bit
so we go to
about if
if it's aging
so with worsenings some conditions we
end up at about 12 million
and the impact on groundwater is not too
large
if we improve the pipelines we can go to
about 15 million instead of 14 million
so
overall it can improve the
it can improve the care and capacity
and
this was an interesting you know
interesting scenario we had reservoir
carrying capacity so we said that what
happens if we increase our
size of our reservoir you know size of
our water towers and save more water so
we have more water for direct
consumption more capacity to save water
for direct consumption
and
what we saw was
surprising because
you know even though population
you know we have a heart
larger
reservoir capacity
so with that
population could increase
however
look at this look at the groundwater
it goes down to
a critical level of 50ck
which is dangerous and which is
something we don't want
so
in the cases that something like this
happens that's where we need
those long-term policies
so we need long-term policies because if
we change you know if we change that
long-term policy from like five years to
to basically 30 years something like
that
we can get
you know groundwater up to instead of
you know 50 ckm we can get bring it up
to about 150 ckm
so prevent it from
going to those critical levels
and at the same but at the same time you
know population ends up being a little
bit lower
was it you know it's gonna go into
um
level off
into a lower
uh sustainable level
and finally
um
this was a story about you know whatever
if we have this uncertainties in our
groundwater estimates because this
happens in lots of places and we can
lose actually some places we can lose
a portion of our groundwater because of
pollution because of dilution with
pollution with chemicals and we can lose
a portion of it so
if you start our groundwater at half the
level so we are 50 uncertain about our
estimate total estimates of groundwater
in this region particularly
what happens as you see
is
well you know population keeps growing
up to this certain point
however you know groundwater goes to
like a very low
levels of about five ckm
and this is really not good
so again this scenario shows how
important it is to have
you know those long-term
plans long-term planning long-term
uh stricter
withdrawal policies
for groundwater sources
so we change that in the scenario and we
show that well you know population has
to drop back down so ends up being at 10
million instead of 13 million in that
period
but
um
we can bring up
the level of groundwater from you know
five six am which is really unacceptable
to something like around 40 camps
so again this example shows how
important it is that we plan
for not just you know not just
one year five years but for longer
future
question yes
breaking the water out as fresh water
groundwater surface water and i think
it's important for people to talk about
fossil water
as well because that doesn't it's not
renewable and some of freshwater
groundwater and surface water those are
just
feedbacks into into
wherever you choose to draw from yeah
but and and big parts of our
agricultural system are dependent upon
fossil water which has no feedback or
renewal
we're thinking about
right and so i i think that
anyhow i think that that's yes
excellent actually excellent question
and suggestion
so
groundwater here you know groundwater
here sort of acts as sort of like a
fossil fuel because it's rate of
replenishing is pretty slow
so
in those places where you're talking you
know fossil water we're pumping some
water out and it's not going to be
replaced and we are using you know
energy to pump it up fossil fuels to
pump it up
this is so that groundwater essentially
includes
includes that water
but you know as you said we can in some
versions of the model you can
separate those and to break them into
like finer distinction
stocks
thinking about groundwater is renewable
where they're really talking
in one hand about fossil water which is
not renewable yeah
yeah that's that's a great suggestion
thank you well have you
i know just if you just like
so this is actually the last the last
slide
so
you know i can again show a comparison
of all these different experiments we
did you know different policies and
different management options that we
looked at
so we can see that you know all of these
things recycling technology can
increase you know the population the
water carrying capacity of the system
and they can conserve water sources and
then we looked at this
surprising scenario for higher reservoir
capacity
that
that could lead to
dangerous depletion of groundwater
sources however we could prevent that
with strict uh withdrawal policies
long-term policies
and these policies are also important
when we had
uh uncertainty high uncertainty in our
estimates for the groundwater sources
so in
conclusion for this we have
you know we can we can make these models
that looks at long-term impacts of water
management options
such as you know recycling technology
transfer infrastructure
reservoir capacity
on the system on the coupled you know
human water system human climate water
system
but we have to
have these bi-directional couplings of
water with population in order to
see all these non-trivial interactions
and non-trivial evolutions of the system
so
it is important
we show that it's very important to have
long-term policies
for water reserves
and
you know we can show in future works
that this should be for all the cases
and you know something related to your
question about fossil fuels so the next
level the model we are working on right
now
is actually an energy model that is
fully coupled with koa
so we integrate the next sector
of our five sector model
uh together with cola with coupled human
climate water and energy
so that's the next level
okay so i think with this i would like
to
conclude my talk i had a slide for final
thoughts you know because i i was told
that this is some i have to give some uh
connections for the computer science
students
and i had final thoughts but i think
we're already cut off maybe andy
are we
cutting off at 5 30 sharp or 5 35. we'll
take the video down
so
finish up and then
well i can i can go with this one
you know the final thoughts i had maybe
i just showed it and i
quickly talked about it
so
for
all the students you know all the
students in computer science and in
other you know other heart sciences
what we think is important is
we need to work together you know earth
scientists computer scientists hard
scientists they have to work together
more closely
with the
policy makers with the decision makers
and with social sciences
so because we are all you know we are
all here to serve
humanity in general
so we have to provide our services to
everyone
and in order to do that we need to make
a smart decisions we need to make smart
policies
because we are
dealing with the human system and as i
showed human systems
greatly
depend upon our decisions their
evolution greatly depends on our
decisions
so
computers
have helped you know over the past
century even shorter half century i
should say
they have helped with so many different
um
endeavors of human
of mankind you know they're using
computers in
uh systems and lots of modeling and
um
in markets and economics we're using it
for so many different things in
healthcare
we're using computers for basically
every lots of different things and
we we could and we should use it a lot
more frequently
for
making better decisions
so that's our you know that's
my goal and
that's why you know i
try to connect you know public policy
with
uh systems modeling
and that's i think
is a place where there's lots of work to
be done there's lots of opening
and i think all the students can
um
can look into that as a possible
possible option for their future work
all right
so
i want to thank you again all for your
attention and for your time
and i would like to with this i would
like to open the floor to
more questions
thank you
yes so have you shown this to the people
of sacramento department of water
resources i have not
i can arrange that if you'd like
i would be happy i will be here until
uh until saturday that's a sunday
actually you know
so
if
if they want to do it you know well no
the problem is you'll have to go to
sacramento this thing i mean
yeah i mean they have a two billion
dollar system
wow but like i think your model is
probably a little on the simple side
with it
it is simple but you know still the
whole point you know was doing the
simple models is
you know we know like for example all
these integrated assessment models you
know they exist they have been around
for years they're complex and
um like gcam for example that's
developed as doe pnml
igsm at mit you know mirage uh image
message all of those models but
i've
commonly seen when
people at these places they present
their work they present you know their
analysis lots of times they see that we
see this thing happening here we don't
really understand why or how it happens
we don't understand you know all those
feedback because we have these thousands
of parameters thousands of variables
and you know those models
they do they serve a purpose you know
they're very accurate they're trying to
you know go with all the data sometimes
you can you can't see all these you know
bi-directional feedbacks and
interactions in the system so this model
yes it is a simple model but you can
clearly see
you know you can clearly see what's
going on what variable changes the
evolution path of these other variables
and in what ways
the state of california on the other
hand
is
it's a couple orders of magnitude larger
because
multiple urban areas
and it's it's largely due for control of
the central valley
where the interests are
heavily agricultural which phoenix is
not
and
i've been in meetings certainly where
you'll say something about like about a
stream going to somebody's property and
they don't care they don't give a rat's
ass who's downstream
that's and that's
largely that's that's uh how water is
governed in this in the state i think
mark twain said it best
whiskey is for drinking and water is for
fighting
you